lorsque j'avais lu dans c'est vous alors
vous a jamais vu danser mais moi j'adore
danser non sérieuse adorait danser à
comment collabore à fait je pense que tu
vas faire une blague
tu m'as tu m'écoutes pas du tout c'est
pas parce que vous vous êtes toujours
classe toujours toujours belle on va
vous mettre des musiques essayé de
danser toujours avec la classe mais en
donnant d'accord attention est-ce qu'il
peut être comme ça taux des prêts à
temps des attentions petite musique
d'abord aux démarques
là il n'était pas du tout au courant
donc je dis ça peut être complètement à
cescau cette séquence
alors attention c'est parti on y va
bah
ma
attention ici là vous êtes sur des
mutations on est dans touche pas à mon
pote la sueur médias et d'enfin sénat on
va faire on va faire un truc
voyager c'est complètement improvisé
cette histoire c'est l'arrivée c'est une
histoire qui suit là vous êtes
tranquillement en boîte parce que tout
le monde vous adore tout le monde
franchement moi je vois une fille comme
vous je ne nage pas d'accord qui est un
podium est arrivé à la maison je ferme
touche unis ça y était madame hanoune à
droite et madame cordula d'accord on va
je vais appeler ça je vais appeler je
m'appelais jean-michel baer la plus sûre
michel mr je veux la paix il pas trop
jeune pour voulu non ça va ça va être
juste mais bien j'ai pas comme vous mais
qu'à ses cheveux les blaireaux sont même
bien regardez vous êtes en boîte en
train de danser d'accord et il ya un
gars vous allez arriver chacun votre
tour
on va le faire aussi il va essayer vous
draguez mandant sont des zones denses et
rossi est le gars va arriver vous vous
voyez vous pouvez le basez vous voyez
pas d'accord on est bien le mec qui
l'attend il est comme ça alors laisser
l'un peut danser au début après vous
auriez compris les bars et par bertrand
chamerois d'abord d'accord
attention c'est parti après ce sera à
vous jean michel sais pas
et
c'est la dame est restée dans son jus
auj
obama
quoi
c'est la jalousie rapport est la classe
il est arrivé avec son costume chirac 90
il est arrivé le gars c'était alain
juppé il est allé comme à son ministre
sur la piste et là c'est parti vivant
pourquoi vous avez choisi le gérant le
box qui est bas parce que ouais tout en
cédant ou à la vérité ça arrive et on
dit qu'il ya du pognon pour le voit rien
dire ou l'ail et du pognon